hey guys this is Meena Massoud I play
Aladdin in Disney's Aladdin
and I am doing first times alright first
time here first time you realized you
wanted to be an actor probably my first
time watching mrs. Doubtfire or rush
hour damn first celebrity you ever met
this is a hard one because I think I'd
meet celebrities a lot but I don't know
who they are I grew up in an Egyptian
household so I'm not very cultured and I
think it's will I think it has to be
Will Smith which is a pretty pretty good
one to be in with first kiss this is
include mouth action or cheeks or fine
what am i how am I supposed to set the
scene here there was these train tracks
behind these train tracks we would get
away from the institution that we were
at I don't want to say either school or
Church probably there I think at least
the first one I remember so the first
one worth remembering tell us about the
first text you sent today I probably
text my publicist and asked her where I
should do my laundry it's not very
exciting first time meeting your co-star
Will Smith we just talked about you will
oh my god so I met him it was during
prep I came up to him I said hello but I
looked like one of the dancers cuz we
were doing dancers also he didn't know
who I was so he was like oh hey what's
up and I thought it was very weird the
way he reacted and then I walked away
and I was like tell him who I was so I
went back and I was like oh by the way
will its Meena Masood and he was like oh
me know what's up and his reaction
totally changed so make sure you always
introduce your name when you're
introducing yourself to people but I was
nervous first person you text when
you're having a bad day my friend Elma
bagel [ __ ] or Joshua Lovato sorry guys
you're losing your privacy as of right
now first reaction after putting on
Aladdin's costume for the first time
probably my classic Mena laugh which if
you haven't heard it yet someone say
something funny ha ha ha alright
actually my first celebrity crush got so
many good ones
Hilary Duff I used to watch Lizzie
McGuire and I asked for her Christmas CD
one Christmas and I got it I may have
kissed the CD with her face on it
sorry if I ever meet you Hilary okay uh
first acting gig Peter Pan in elementary
school I played Peter Pan and did not
get paid for it in grade eight
unfortunately otherwise I would have
bought myself some nice Pokemon cards
couldn't afford those first time you
bombed an audition I probably forgot my
lines but I will tell you when I like
out of first time I bought my one of my
first jobs I was supposed to play this
Afghan soldier who had this head trauma
and eventually he dies because of this
head trauma and I was supposed to be was
supposed to be in pain and I was trying
to do and I wasn't getting it and the
director came over and she's like I'm
not feeling it and I was like I know I'm
just I'm not feeling it and she stopped
me and she said you're an actor it's
your job to make me feel like you feel
it and that hit home I was like that is
my job I think I've been better ever
since first memory that comes to mind
when you hear the word Egypt
sunrise first bad haircut probably a
mushroom cut my parents were big fans of
that I think it was popular in Egypt or
something and they just decided to bring
that over to Toronto
not a good move parents know
of good tell me about your first pet
I've never really had a pet so to be to
be continued seriously I don't know
sorry was anticlimactic guys alright so
that was my first time here at BuzzFeed
I had a blast thank you for having me
and make sure you go watch Aladdin's May
24th
[Music]